hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe I'm your host Sean
Carroll today we're going to be
continuing on the theme that we already
started in the last video we started in
the last video we talked about the idea
of fields quantum fields in particular
and this is such a deep and rich topic
it's gonna take more than one video to
get through all of what's interesting
about quantum field theory in fact in
the last video really all we did was
established that if you had free fields
that just say fields that didn't
interact with each other or even
themselves then you could think of them
as collections of particles today we're
gonna take the next obvious step and let
them interact with each other so today's
big idea is interactions and the way to
do that is of course like many of these
videos I have the title then I have what
I really want to talk about what I'm
really talking about today are Fineman
diagrams and how we use vitamin diagrams
to calculate the interactions between
quantum fields thought of as collections
of particles so to remember where we are
we have classical field configurations
oops yeah let's try to make that
prettier ok classical fields which is
our starting point have a configuration
and we just started with the simplest
case of a scalar field scalar field
meaning just that at every point in
space there is a real number a value for
that field
more complicated examples would be
vectors or tensors or spinners or
whatever and then we quantize it okay so
we get a quantum wave function and that
is just an assignment to every possible
field configuration of some complex
number so this is not Phi at X but the
configuration of five for all X's gets a
complex number capital psy that is the
amplitude for that particular field
configuration so you might have in just
a simple one-dimensional example if this
is space X and this is the value of our
field Phi you have some configuration
and you call that Phi 1 of X and the
wave function assigns a complex number
called the
sigh of y12 that particular
configuration yeah some other
configuration over here this is all when
I say over here I mean over here on the
pad that I'm writing on not there in
space all these configurations are
hypothetical possible configurations of
the field in space so here's another
configuration you could have call that
Phi 2 and the quantum theory you would
have an amplitude for that being the
actual field configuration and then you
measure it you observe the field
everywhere somehow and the probability
of observing some particular field
configuration Phi is just the wave
function for Phi absolute value squared
that's the born rule for quantum field
theory good so that's a big abstract
mess and we needed to learn how to sort
of make some sense of it to turn it into
something useful and what we did was to
show that in this simple spherical cow
world where we had free fields not
interacting with each other we could
first decompose them into modes that is
to say into collections of plane waves
of field configurations that are just
sine waves all throughout space with a
certain direction they're moving in a
certain wavelength and then we could
treat each mode one by one and a
wonderful spectacularly helpful thing
happened
each mode behaves like a simple harmonic
oscillator we know how to deal with
simple harmonic oscillators
so in particular simple harmonic
oscillators have a lowest energy state a
next highest energy state a next highest
energy state and so forth and it turns
out that we can interpret this formalism
in the case of the modes of a quantum
field as corresponding to zero particle
States one particle States
two particle States and so forth so we
have modes of a field and we could write
those as Phi sub K K is the wave vector
it tells you the wavelength in the
direction that the field is moving in as
a function of H the height so very
roughly speaking you have some sine wave
here this is X this is Phi K and the
wavelength which is the distance
let's say two troughs lambda is 2 PI
over the size of K and the height is
just this tiny value here H the
amplitude of the highest peak in the
sine wave and so we showed that modes of
a field are like simple harmonic
oscillators of course there are an
infinite number of modes so that's an
infinite number of simple harmonic
oscillators vibrating all throughout
space and we can quantize a simple
harmonic oscillators solve the
Schrodinger equation one by one and we
find that there are energy levels
equally spaced and then we interpret
those energy levels as collections of
particles so at the end of the day a
quantum field is just an organizational
tool I should say just is an
organizational tool for talking about
many collections of particles and in
fact collections superpositions of
different numbers of particles I should
also say that this is in the spherical
cow regime where the field is non
interacting things become a little bit
more complicated when they interact a
little bit we're gonna ignore all those
complications but when the fields
interact by a lot or the fields do
something dramatic this description in
terms of particles might be completely
off-base there are absolutely situations
in which the field enos of the quantum
field really does matter that it's not
just the cheap substitute for thinking
about particles hopefully we'll get a
chance to talk about some of those
situations later on okay so real fields
I don't mean the real numbers I mean
actual fields in the world are not free
that is to say they do interact so we
have to sort of turn on the interactions
a little bit just like Galileo could
drop a ball and say well let's ignore
air resistance and put it in later we're
starting with free fields and then we're
putting in interactions later so in fact
what happens is that particles you can
still think of them as particles this is
the the wonderful thing about field
theory even when we turn on the
interactions you can still think of them
as part
they scatter I'm not gonna write all
this down they scattered dot they can
scatter off each other they can
annihilate they can decay write a
neutron decays into a proton and
electron and antineutrino they can
create other particles and il-8 and so
forth they can recombine so we want to
invent some way of thinking about this
we made a huge step by going from
quantum fields to particles but we want
to do the next step so what does that
involve
so here's what we should be thinking
about the the nice thing as I as I said
as I hinted at if you hear some
scratching in the background I think
that's Caliban he's a little bit excited
this time of day the thing that we can
do is not only think the free fields as
particles but continue to think of them
as particles even when we turn on
interactions the difference is unlike
ordinary non field theory quantum
mechanics the number of particles is not
a conserved quantity the wave function
of the quantum field is a superposition
like I said of different numbers of
particles and the Schrodinger equation
that tells you how that wave function
evolves can change the number of
particles through different kinds of
interactions so we want a way of dealing
with that but nevertheless we're gonna
deal with it by thinking of it as
particles oK we've sort of used the
field NIST to justify that we can think
of it as particles for the rest of this
lecture it's particles all the way now I
keep calling them lectures they're
videos there are nice informal videos
they're not lectures don't be
intimidated okay so what we're thinking
of is a collection of particles and we
start by imagining the particles are
unentangled so despite all the Cupra
about saying that there's only one wave
function of the universe we start by
saying that there are two different
particles let's say if we're doing the
scattering experiment two different
particles that have their own wave
functions so here is particle one with
its wave function it's traveling this
way here's particle two it's
wavefunction traveling that way and this
under the short agur equation is going
to evolve into I'm gonna draw it bigger
because it's going to be more fun lots
of little particles going out in all
different directions right these little
blobs I'm drawing you're supposed to be
little wave packets a wave packet is
just a little bit of wave function this
sort of localized
to one region of space and you can make
these wave packets as we said even by
superimposing plane ways that stretch
all over space that's kind of the fun
thing about the Fourier transform you
can get a localized function by summing
up a bunch of functions that are
certainly not localized ok so this is
the transition through time between
let's say two particles coming in
scattering out and this picture on the
left is perfectly sensible we start with
two different particles unentangled they
have their own wave functions the
picture on the right is entirely
suggestive and not very sensible because
after we're gonna have a situation where
there's a lot of entanglement it's not
gonna be that crucial but it's there but
more importantly it will be a
superposition of all sorts of different
numbers of particles so will not look
anything like this nice neat thing where
you have just a certain collection of
wave packets that are all separate from
each other the individual components of
the wave function will look that way so
that's what we're gonna do we're gonna
sort of do it chants fight chants right
you have two particles coming in let's
analyze the idea that they scatter in
two particles scattering the three
particles scatter the four particles
etc but how do you actually calculate
that and you know I'm gonna give you
sort of a half-baked
explanation of this by the end you will
not actually be able to calculate
anything at all but you will know how
the calculations are done at least half
of the ideas behind them so if you ever
want to pick up a book on quantum field
theory you'll be very prepared
conceptually to follow what's what's
going on and it was of course richard
fineman who figured out the way that we
all do this in the brilliant idea of
Fineman diagrams and 5min diagrams
you've all seen them right the little
pictures a little cartoon stick figures
of particles coming together but one
thing that emphasized here is that
they're not just pictures you might
think if you just if you didn't go too
deeply into what's going on here that
the Fineman diagrams are just
representations of things that can
happen you know the two electrons can
scatter off of each other by exchanging
a photon but they're much more than that
every Fineman diagram is a number it is
a way of calculating a number and that
number is a contribution to the
amplitude to the quantum mechanical wave
function for that set of part
pickles that are going out of the
Fineman diagram so the initial particles
in the Fineman diagram represent a
starting wave functions the outgoing
particles represent a contribution to
the final wave function environment gave
us a recipe he didn't just say this was
a good idea to think about he actually
told us how to do it so he said that
there are basis that we can think of
some basic set of interactions so by
interaction I mean let's say an electron
can absorb a photon that's an example of
interaction and then we combine them in
all possible ways so if you start with
some idea that you're going to ask well
how can electron and a positron which is
an anti-electron how can they scatter
off of each other to form just another
electron and positron not change their
identity just you know scatter off of
each other in some way well by starting
with that fundamental interaction of
photons and electrons you'll see you
will see in a second there's a lot of
different ways to combine them to get
that final interaction and Fineman says
do them all combine them all this is
quantum mechanics everything that can
happen is going to contribute to what's
going on you know in the back of his
mind he was inventing the path integral
formulation of quantum mechanics where
literally if you just remove point
particles every trajectory the particle
can take will contribute to the final
answer that was sort of an inspiration
for Fineman diagrams but you don't need
to know anything about the path integral
way of doing quantum mechanics to do
Feynman diagrams it's much more
straightforward than that and then you
calculate the number using this
combination the amplitude
and you know what to do with the
amplitude when someone hands you a
quantum mechanical amplitude the
probability of whatever final state
you're considering is that amplitude for
that final state square so I do this I
write this over and over again so I
really do want to emphasize this fact I
already mentioned that quantum field
theory is not a replacement for quantum
mechanics it's a specific example of
quantum mechanics all the rules of
quantum mechanics are still here in
quantum field theory it's just the thing
we're quantizing our fields not
particles okay so that here's an example
the example I just mentioned let's think
about an electron and a positron
remember that Paul Dirac taught us that
there's things called anti particles so
an electron is a tiny particle with a
negative charge and a positron is a tiny
particle with a positive charge which is
the anti particle of the electron but
because the electron was discovered
first and it's more important for our
lives we write the electron as E - it is
the electron with a negative charge the
positron we don't write as P because P
is for proton we write the positron as a
plus it's the anti particle the electron
we're gonna take an electron and
positron and ask if they scatter into an
electron and another positron so they
don't change their identity they just
maybe change their momentum they
literally bump into each other now this
is not the only thing that could happen
you know you're not done okay you would
also like to calculate the probability
that this electron and positron do
everything else that they can do and we
will have a way of doing that but for
right now we're focusing on this
particular final state so we can find
the probability of that and roughly you
know schematically before we get into
the details the picture is we have time
running left to right so again different
ways of thinking about physics
conventionally choose different ways for
time to run in relativity and space time
time runs from bottom to top in particle
physics sometimes it does that but more
often it goes left to right and there
are studies I mentioned Larry Bird it's
key you know people who are Hebrew
eaters or other people who read
right-to-left sometimes make it go right
to left
so we will do left to right because
that's my culture that I come from and
we start with an electron and a positron
and we draw lines representing these
particles moving through time and then
stuff happens okay so this is a blob
that I'm going to label stuff happens
and will be a little bit more specific
about that in a second and then I'll
emerge another electron and a positron
when I say another one because they need
not in principle be the same ones
there's in sent some sense no such thing
as the same ones you know these
electrons and positrons are vibrations
in the underlying electron and positron
field so they do not have any personal
identity over time okay but this is the
the kind of interaction that we want to
think about we want to know how do we
actually calculate numbers for this okay
well Flyman gave us the rule he says we
start with some basic set of
interactions for this process what we do
the scattering we're gonna do it in the
context of quantum electrodynamics okay
QED as it is called quantum
electrodynamics that is finally wrote a
nice little book about it at a semi
popular level that you can that you can
pick up in stores it is the first really
successful full-blown interacting
quantum field theory it was the center
of focus for people like Fineman and
schwinger and tomonaga when they were
thinking about renormalization the
interactions and all that stuff and it's
the theory of just electrons positrons
and photons so it's electrons and
positrons interacting with themselves
and with each other but only through
electromagnetism so we're not worried
about the weak nuclear force or gravity
or anything like that okay so in that
context we have one fundamental
interaction and sometimes because we're
in Feynman diagram land we talk about
interactions as vertices so the vertex
in quantum electrodynamics is an
electron comes in positron comes in and
they hit each other and a photon comes
out photons are
for historical reasons and particle
physics photons are labeled gamma okay
so this is this is a photon so here's
the interaction and there's one more
little notational thing that happens
which is that there is a feature of
electrons and positrons that there is a
certain amount of electron NISS which is
conserved okay in quantum
electrodynamics and other theories it's
not but in QED the electrons are neither
created or destroyed what they can do is
travel backwards in time so this is the
famous idea of Fineman that he actually
he popularized if he got it from someone
else whose name I'm forgetting right now
but the idea that you can think of anti
particles as particles traveling
backwards in time and of course it's
only a matter of our human prejudice
that we label electrons particles and
positrons anti particles the point is
that they are anti particles of each
other it's just as fair to say the
electron is an anti particle the
positron as it is the other way around
but we are full of electrons so we you
know give preference privileged to the
electrons so we draw a little arrow on
the line to represent the direction in
which the electron is moving and because
the positron can be thought of as an
electron going backward in time we draw
the arrow backward okay so you gotta get
this straight the particles are moving
from left to right the electron is for
the electron is therefore moving left to
right but because the positron can be
thought of as an electron going backward
in time the electron this is going right
to left in the case of the positron okay
so these arrows do not represent the
direction of motion of the particles
they represent the flow of this quantity
called electron s which by the way no
one ever uses the word electron s but
it's the closest you'll get is something
called Fermi on number and we'll talk
about what that means but electrons are
forming a number +1 positrons are Fermi
on number minus 1 okay and this is the
fundamental interaction from which we
will build all of our quantum
electrodynamics diagrams and the final
piece of information need to know is
like I said there is a number attached
to this you use these pictures to
calculate the amplitude and the number
that is
- this vertex is the square root of
alpha alpha is the fine-structure
constant and you'll see why it's the
square root in a second the
fine-structure constant is just a way of
thinking about how strong the
electromagnetic interaction is right
it's a dimensionless number alpha is
approximately 1 over 137 there was a
time when people thought maybe it was
exactly 1 over 137 and tried to explain
that using numerology that didn't work
this is not exactly 137 but the number
137 still holds a precious precious
place in the minds of particle
physicists so the fine-structure
constant is a small number it's less
than 1% right it tells us how strong the
electromagnetic interaction is and every
one of these vertices gets a factor of
the square root of alpha so one thing to
keep in mind here is that this is
reassuring to us the fact that alpha is
small because we're thinking of these
interactions as tiny perturbations on
top of the spherical cow of the free
field theory if the interactions were
really really strong you couldn't do
that right putting on the interactions
would change everything in a dramatic
way the fact that alpha is small is what
lets us get away with this way of
thinking about interactions in quantum
field theories ok
and there is one rule you need to know
the rule is you can flip particles lines
of particles let's say these lines are
called the propagators but we won't get
into that detail the lines that we're
drawing on the climate diagrams that's
all you need to know we can flip the
lines between it in and out so if a
particle is coming in and this electron
and then we have a certain diagram we
can draw then we know there is another
diagram where the particle is coming out
and we just flipped it literally sort of
moving it over the arrow now changes its
direction at which it's moving
so by interchanging particles with anti
particles
so what that means is we drew this
diagram with an electron and positron
coming in a photon coming out we said
that's associated with the number alpha
so particles go to anti particles means
eehm eyeness gets interchanged with E
Plus electrons become positrons and
vice-versa the photon in this way of
thinking is its own antiparticle so
photons just remain photons there's no
electric charge that would have to
change assign photons or neutral
particles so they're just their own anti
particles in this way of thinking and
therefore this diagram let me shrink you
down a little bit here this diagram
implies the existence of a couple of
other diagrams it implies the existence
of a diagram where an electron comes in
and we take that positron line and move
it over from coming in to going out and
therefore we get a photon going out
gamma and guess what another electron
coming out so this is another diagram
another interaction where rather than
two particles positron electron coming
in and annihilating into a photon we
have an electron just spitting out a
photon but it's the same Fineman diagram
status so this diagram also comes with
the square root of alpha associated with
it and likewise we can flip both
particles both electron and positron on
the other side and make the photon come
in and these go into a minus E Plus okay
also associated with the factor
numerical factor of square root of alpha
and so forth and you can do other things
as well once you get inside the middle
of more complicated climate diagrams
there's a lot of different things that
you can imagine doing okay so I mean
that's that's already kind of nice right
it's kind of a little bit of a
unification in some sense this is saying
that there's something happening
something that could happen called the
annihilation of an electron and a
positron into a photon there's a certain
number the fine-structure constant that
tells us how likely that is there's a
completely different sounding thing
which is the photon can be
given off by an electron or by a
positron equally well and that also is
characterized by the same number and
this is why at the Fineman diagram level
because they're just the same climbing
diagram flipping some particles from
past to future because remember time is
going this way and all these pictures
okay
so let's put it all together that we
want to calculate an electron and a
positron going into a photon no sorry
that's not what we calculate we want to
calculate these going into another
electron and positron okay so how can we
do that well Flyman says basic set of
interactions that's what we got combine
them in all possible ways okay so given
that we want to start with e minus E
Plus we have P minus E Plus they go into
this what what can they possibly do all
they can do is do that fundamental
interaction that we drew right that's
the only thing that we can start with in
this picture I can keep it prettier than
that and then they turn into a photon
but the photon isn't what we want coming
out we want an electron and a positron
but guess what the photon can spit out
an electron in positron
so here's our arrows II - EEP Loess okay
and that's a photon in the middle this
vertex gets a factor of alpha this
vertex gets a factor of alpha so there's
a number associated with this diagram
which is approximately alpha the
fine-structure constant that's why it's
a square root of alpha because
historically things like this are what
happened and so we use alpha to
characterize this by the way when we
square it to get a probability that'll
be alpha squared anyway so this is a
process that contributes and it gives a
number we can calculate the probability
that the electron and the positron will
scatter off of each other there are
other factors that matter right the fact
that if you have an electron and
positron far away they're less likely to
scatter than electron and a positron
very nearby that comes into other
details that I'm just not worrying about
right now so called kinematic factors
what is the position and the momentum
etc of the wave packets coming in but
this is the fundamental quantum field
theory nests of the calculation but it's
actually not the only thing that can
contribute right because I said the only
thing the electron and positron can do
is emit a photon but there is another I
yeah I'm realizing that was a complete
and total lie now that I say it out loud
now that I think about it it is true
that the electron has to sort of emit a
photon the electron cannot sort of
directly interact with the positron
without emitting a photon but there is
another way to draw that which is this e
minus E Plus okay the electron comes in
and it emits a photon the positron comes
in and it absorbs a photon look at that
I'm sure all the particle physicists the
audience were laughing at me when I said
there's only one way to draw the first
one this is backwards this is another
perfectly good diagram also of order
alpha right the same size roughly
speaking as a contribution to the final
amplitude and we would add them together
this is in fact an example of quantum
interference these these diagrams have a
typical size of order alpha the
fine-structure constant but I didn't
tell you what they are positive or
negative or they can even be you know
imaginary components they're complex
numbers in general all of quantum
mechanics is about complex amplitudes
remember in the QED a video for quantum
mechanics we talked about the double
slit experiment and the fact that it's a
crucial feature of quantum mechanics
that the wave function is not just a
probability distribution it can have
positive and negative values and it can
interfere and that sort of makes us
think the wave function is a real
physical thing this is still quantum
mechanics we're doing these are
contributions to the wave function we
will add them together and then Square
to get the probability of what's
happening and these can interfere with
each other and that interference has
been observed in experiments all the
Fineman diagrams give you separate
contributions you have to add them up
and they can cancel out to give zero
there are situations where there's a
certain kind of process that you would
think
happen if you just threw one vitamin
diagram but it doesn't actually happen
because all the diagrams just cancel out
and you get zero at the end of the day
so it's still quantum mechanics there
can be interference the other thing to
say is to go back I said that this is
not the only thing that can happen right
so there's another process there's also
processes like this fun one where an
electron and a positron come in and you
go like this so you have two photons
coming out and the electron this goes
this way comes out that way okay so this
is a different process this is not a -
e+ goes to e - e plus this is e - e plus
goes to two photons it's another thing
that can happen you would not add this
to the previous pieman diagrams because
it's contributing to a different final
state just like in the double slit
experiment the interference happens at
every point on the detector you add up
what the contributions are there you
don't add up contributions at different
points of the detector you add up
contributions to the same final state so
these two diagrams contribute to the
same final state electron and a positron
this diagram and once like it contribute
to different final states so they're
there but there's different processes we
don't have to go into them right now
okay so in fact let me just get rid of
these because they're there I didn't
want you to think that you know we were
done but let's let's continue on with
this particular process we're not done
even now drawing you might think are you
like think about it all this looks like
all the diagrams we can draw not true
there are an infinite number of diagrams
we can draw so in fact there's an
infinite series and that kind of becomes
important the infinite series is because
let's draw it this way we have just very
schematically we have this blob that
represents stuff happening okay what
we're saying is there's a contribution
that looks like this once you get good
at the Fineman diagrams you stop drawing
the arrows and the labels with E - and E
Plus you can also label these individual
lines these propagators with their
momentum and their energy these are
properties that they have but you just
keep those in mind implicitly and stop
drawing them so as a diagram like this
there's another diagram that we drew
that looks like this okay but there's
also diagrams let me see what I chose to
draw here's a diagram with two photons
going back and forth and of course once
you realize that then you realized
there's an arbitrary number of photons
that's clearly going to be an infinite
number of diagrams like I could put
three photons for photons five photons
it doesn't stop in any way but there's
also different kinds of diagrams here's
a diagram where the electron positron
and I lead to a photon then the photon
creates an electron and a positron but
they reunite into a photon and then they
go off right that that contributes to
the final answer there's one where the
electron and positron come in and I like
to a photon but another photon gets
exchanged between them before they
annihilate and then they go off and then
you know as you can imagine they become
more and more complicated so this seems
like bad news this seems like oh my
goodness we're trying to do some simple
calculation there's an infinite number
of things I have to calculate and that
sounds bad but in fact that's not bad
remember alpha is approximately 1 over
137 so relatively tiny number and every
one of these vertices comes with a
square root of alpha so the more
vertices you get like something here you
have let's colorize it some like this
diagram you have 1 2 3 4 vertices as
opposed to over here you only have to
write so you will in fact get more and
more an infinite number of diagrams but
only more more complicated diagrams
we've drawn all the simple diagrams
already and as the diagrams become more
more complicated this diagram looks like
alpha this one looks like alpha but this
one looks like alpha squared as does
this alpha squared alpha squared and
higher order diagrams will look like
alpha cubed alpha 4th etc because alpha
is less than 1 as you raise it to higher
and higher powers you get a smaller and
smaller number so the hope with Fineman
diagrams which will be partially real
exactly realized but in a complicated
non-trivial weighing the hope is that
even though there's an infinite number
of diagrams these diagrams become less
and less important and in fact in
practice you don't have to calculate an
infinite number of diagrams you have to
calculate the small number of important
ones to get an answer that is really
really good it becomes harder and harder
to calculate the diagrams as they get
bigger and bigger I'm leaving out a lot
of details about what you actually have
to do to calculate them but you get the
basic scaling going on here so this is
an example of perturbation theory which
I mentioned before perturbation theory
in action perturbation theory is the
idea that you can start with something
you understand perfectly like free
fields or a ball falling without any air
resistance and you can add in tiny
effects and add them as perturbations so
the way that the reason why that works
is because they generally in
perturbation theory more generally not
just in this context you get an infinite
power series by power series I mean so
you get an infinite series an infinite
series let's say a for the amplitude
we're looking at can be written as a 0
plus a 1 plus a 2 plus dot dot where a n
is proportional to alpha it's terrible
that the proportionality sign looks like
an alpha so I'm going to say some other
number epsilon to the power n some small
number epsilon epsilon is less than 1 so
this general feature is that all of the
terms in the series are smaller than the
previous terms because they are
proportional to epsilon to some power
and epsilon is a small number you might
worry you might say well proportional to
covers a great deal of sins you know
maybe the constant of proportionality is
really big for some term later on and
actually that's just a legit word you
should worry about that I'm not going to
poopoo that in practice if you're
dealing with well-behaved systems
perturbation Theory works very well
ignoring powers of epsilon to the
thousandth power R is a pretty good
approximate
but you have to be careful things can go
wrong things can be subtle but this is
that this is the thing that most
particle physicists learn to do when
they learn their quantum field theory of
course the other thing that can happen
is so this this feature here that you're
a power series in a small number means
that your interactions are weak and now
what I mean is by weak I mean not very
strong physicists love to use the same
words in different contexts to mean
different things so there is an
interaction in particle physics that
we'll talk about later called the weak
nuclear force it's a dumb name for an
important interaction so sometimes when
you say weakly interacting particles
like the dark matter candidates weakly
interacting massive particles
what you mean is particles that are
interacting through the weak nuclear
force other times like here all you mean
is particles that are interacting
through some interaction that is not
that strong okay so this is just an
interaction that is feeble and when
interactions are feeble perturbation
Theory works not always true in the so
called strong nuclear force guess what
the interactions are not weak they're
not even feeble they are strong the
thing that you might think is a
parameter the thing that plays the role
of alpha in the strong nuclear force can
be greater than one
and if this epsilon here in this power
series were greater than one this power
series would be useless every term would
be bigger than the previous term and
they would never add up to some finite
number so it's not always true that
perturbation Theory works but it's very
is a very good approximation for a lot
of very important problems certainly for
QED through quantum electrodynamics it
works very well okay so we let's do a
little bit more digging into the details
here so I said that this fundamental
interaction in QED was proportional to
the square root of alpha says who like
who who invented that rule right well
tell ya it was I mean the rules were
invented by Fineman but they are ways of
expressing rules that were already
invented so Fineman diagrams are a
calculational tool for dealing with
quantum field theory so if I'm a did not
invent
quantum field theory but he figured out
how to work with it in a plausible way
in a way that everyone could do and you
know there's the the joke that he tells
like when he was first scribbling these
diagrams he was immensely amused by the
idea that if his idea panned out the
physics journals would now be full of
these slow scribbles and indeed you know
the first time that he scribbled these
things on a blackboard at a seminar he
got made merciless fun of and now you
open any physics journal it's full of
Lyman diagrams so the rules where does
it come from how do we assign numbers to
vertices to interactions well you know
even though we're doing quantum
mechanics it's still physics so remember
we did for classical mechanics we talked
about the Newtonian paradigm with F
equals MA but then we also talked about
the Hamiltonian way of doing things
where you have phase space and
Hamilton's equations and we also talked
about the principle of least action
where you had some integral of some
quantity over time and the minimum of
that action that integral was the actual
physical thing that you did the actual
physical path that a real particle would
take so the another thing that Fineman
figured out is that you can this is this
goes back to the path integral formalism
is that you can do quantum mechanics
with an action but rather than saying
here's an action that is an integral
over all time and the minimum value of
the action is the real one in quantum
mechanics they're all real but they
don't all count the same the minimum
value of the action is the one that will
add up to the biggest contribution to
the quantum amplitude but they're all
there in some sense quantum mechanics
takes advantage of all the different
trajectories the system could take so it
turns out for completely other reasons
that if you're going to invent new laws
of physics that are not new laws of
physics but a model for physics that you
don't yet understand it is way simpler
more convenient to work with an action
than it is to write down the equivalent
of Newton's laws to write down the
equations of motion for the fields to
write down the equivalent of Maxwell's
equations the reason I'll tell you the
reason the reason is because these
fields often have
symmetries we'll get into that later but
the symmetries matter a lot and it is
way easier to implement the symmetries
in the context of writing down in action
than it is in the context of writing out
individual equations of motion and that
goes back to the feature that we
mentioned earlier about these
alternatives to Newtonian mechanics
which is that they're often either in
the action formalism or in the
Hamiltonian formalism they're written
down in terms of a single function the
action the Hamiltonian you don't have to
guess separately the equations of motion
for every field you can write down one
action and all the fields equations of
motion come from that one object so
we're gonna go back to the action in
this particular way of doing things it
will look classical but we will use it
in a quantum mechanical way so the
principle of least action says that we
have an action s and there's an integral
of kinetic energy of your particle or
your system more generally - the
potential energy and then you integrate
that over time DT so remember integrals
are sums so we're saying at every moment
do you evaluate this quantity kinetic -
potential you add them all up over all
the different moments of time now the
fact that you take this quantity and you
integrate over time is always true so we
often just forget the fact that we are
integrating it over time again that's
implicit in our background knowledge and
we deal directly with this quantity
which is called the Lagrangian the
Lagrangian is just the kinetic energy
minus potential energy is the thing you
integrate over time to get the action so
you can write down s equals something
but it's much more common to write down
L equals something so s equals the
integral of L DT okay that's a nice way
of saying what we want to do to invent
our new theory is to invent the
Lagrangian for that theory
okay so saying this is true this is true
in the context of particles moving in
potentials and things like that but the
same idea is true for fields but fields
are a little bit more complicated right
they're spread out all over space there
could be different kinds of fields they
could be vectors etc
so you as you might expect the
Lagrangian for fields is in principle a
little bit more complicated but not that
much
so for fields Lagrangian L can be
thought of as the kinetic energy minus
something called the gradient energy we
mentioned this before the kinetic energy
is the field changing over time the
gradient energy is the fields profile
over space but we're not done yet
there is still minus the potential
energy so this is saying that in some
theories of physics the value of the
field itself contains energy when the
field has zero value maybe at zero
energy maybe not but maybe when the
field is some large value that contains
energy that's the potential the
potential is not the derivative of
anything that's what makes it the
potential then also since we have more
than one field in our game we have an
interaction energy so if you have
electrons and photons for example in
quantum field theory they are both
described by fields and there better be
a term in your Lagrangian that tells how
those fields interact with each other
and that's what this term is so the game
that is played by particle physicists
the world over is to write down
different lagrangian's for different
theories of fields interacting in
different ways now they do have one more
big simplification locality locality in
this sense means that two fields
interact with each other two different
fields or the same field in itself only
when they are at exactly the same point
in space so two fields far away might
interact with each other indirectly
like the earth can interact and the
earth is made of fields in quantum field
theory so is everything else so is the
Sun made of quantum fields they can
interact with each other through gravity
but only because there's a gravitational
field in between in some very strict
sense the earth interacts with the
gravitational field locally so does the
Sun and that interacts back in all the
way over in between so the the way that
locality manifests
itself in this language is that the
Lagrangian for a quantum field is an
integral over space of something which
we call the Lagrangian s'ti and the
Lagrangian city is a function of the
field Phi and its derivatives oops
I can't spell anymore I'll just say the
derivative so I'm not gonna try to
notational eyes that integrated over all
of space so this curly L is the
Lagrangian s'ti density is just
something that we have at every point in
space and then we integrated over
everything to get a whole quantity right
if you have energy density that exists
at a point in space the energy in the
volume is the integral of the energy
density over that whole volume the
LeGrande
density exists at every point in space
and we integrate all over all space to
get the total value of the Lagrangian so
this d3x is representing an
infinitesimally tiny cube in space okay
DX dy DZ that's what the notation d3 X
means and this is just a yo an
underappreciated fact about quantum
field theory so it doesn't need to be
this in fact let me be a little bit more
clear here let's let me notice something
here well it didn't quite work but close
enough the fields are functions of X
right so the field is Phi at the point X
so when you're integrating over space
both the fields and their derivatives
have a value at every point and what
this is saying is one field at point x
interacts with other fields at point x
naught with not at point y so it is not
for example we could imagine taking you
know Phi of X Phi 1 of X and a different
field Phi 2 of Y and integrating d3 x d3
y so we integrate twice over space and
have fields all over the place
interacting with each other that would
be spooky action at a distance right
that would not be local that would be
bad so let's just put a big X to that
that's not what we do
this way of writing the Lagrangian for a
quantum field theory is just an enormous
ly important feature of a reality the
laws of physics didn't have to be that
way they didn't have to be local now we
talked in the video about space about
the interesting fact that there is this
thing called space in which interactions
are local why is that no one knows why
but we know that it's true and so in
quantum field theory we take advantage
of that in quantum gravity it might not
be true this is why I keep emphasizing
this because I'm trying to teach you
ways that you know you eventually you're
gonna grow up to be Nobel Prize winners
who quantized gravity there's
indications in quantum gravity that
locality is not as important as it is in
quantum field theory but right now we're
doing quantum field theory work
localities absolutely 100% central ok so
because the action is always the
integral over time of the Lagrangian and
the Lagrangian is always the integral
over space of Lagrangian s'ti the thing
that particle physicists actually spend
their time doing is inventing Lagrange
densities ok and that's from the
Lagrangian s'ti that we will get our
rule for the Fineman diagrams so the QFT
recipe quantum field theory what do you
do if you want to be a grown-up quantum
field theories first you invent a set of
free fields and you write down their
well kinetic energy gradient energy and
potential energy right that's an easy
enough thing to do and then you know you
have the different kinds of fields maybe
then you decide what symmetries the
fields have can't go into this in detail
right now need a whole another video to
talk about symmetries but symmetries
turn out to be SuperDuper important in
quantum field theory whether or not it's
things like gauge invariance which is a
feature of electromagnetism and the
nuclear forces or just position
invariance time translation invariance
all these things symmetries will
restrict the different number of terms
you can write down in your interaction
LeGrande
and then that's what you do you
construct an interaction Lagrangian that
is the thing that we indicated will
exist oh by the way yet another abuse of
grunge and yeah I got it right
another abuse of language because the
Lagrangian is always the integral of the
grunge density not only field theorists
particle physicists worry about the
grunge densities they get tired of
saying the word density over and over
again so you will often refer to this
curly L thing the thing that you
integrate over all space to get the
Lagrangian as the Lagrangian so I will
do that too so curly L is the really
LaGrant entity but we call the
Lagrangian okay so this term here
interaction energy is the interaction
Lagrangian okay the thing that we want
to great over space to get the actual
Lagrangian so for example for an example
we already have an example of one
interaction an electron a positron and a
photon can interact with each other in a
certain way so we right L QED it's the
interaction Lagrangian for quantum
electrodynamics and I should polish to
mention that in a real quantum field
theory textbook they will spend pages
and pages of introducing new notation
and a lot of Greek letters and things
like that I've already used all bunch of
Greek letters myself but I'm trying to
keep it as straightforward as possible
so my doe tation is different but
roughly speaking it is a number the
square root of alpha again I'm hiding
some four pies and things like that
times the electron field times the
positron field times the photon field
this is the electron this is the
positron this is the photon these E's
have nothing to do with you know
two-point-seven the Euler's constant
gamma has nothing to do there's another
constant the euler mesh roni constant
I'm not going to pronounce it correctly
but these are fields this is e minus of
X is the electron field
gamma in this very very simplified
notation is the photon field and
likewise for the positron field the
reason why I'm sort of slightly smiling
and saying that it's a simplified
notation is the real photon field is a
vector so it has indices it has
directions and it's gauge invariant and
it's a whole number of things you need
to think about the real electron field
and the positron fields are spinners and
they have their anti particles and there
are more indices yet to worry about but
forget about all that we don't need to
worry about that what matters is there's
a term in the Lagrangian that has an
electron field hitting a photon field
and a positron field and together from
them you get the interaction so this is
the rule this is literally called the
Fineman rules given this interaction
lagrangian you get that this particular
diagram
II - he plus gamma gets the number
square root of alpha the existence of a
term in the Lagrangian with an electron
field positron field and a photon field
times a number means that there is a
Fineman diagram with those three
particles and the size of that Fineman
diagram that interaction that vertex is
the number whatever that number is in
this case it happens to be the square
root of the fine-structure constant and
so this is the game that you play as a
professional particle physicist you
invent different Lagrange ten cities for
different fields with different
symmetries and so forth okay so you can
see I hope you can see the basic outline
I wonder how small I can actually shrink
this yeah you can see the basic outline
well look we've done a lot of stuff how
awesome are we but there's a lot of
details okay and what I want to do is
rather than focusing on computational
details right now I want to give you one
little conceptual detail to close things
off a Fineman diagram
this is a point about what is actually
physically going on when you look at a
fireman diagram it's a story and it's
not even an especially accurate story
finding diagrams are a way of
calculating something that is very
rigorous and well-defined the amplitude
for the wavefunction of the quantum
fields to have a certain to be a certain
number in a certain final state that you
care about but the steps along the way
have a different kind of status so by
the way there's one thing I should have
said I realized a while ago so when you
when I wrote this diagram here you
notice that for some of these diagrams
or for this diagram well yeah for this
diagram I wasn't very careful about
whether the photon was going from left
to right or right to left that's because
you actually sort of it doesn't matter
that really is what what matters because
the photon is its own antiparticle so
whether it's going forward in time where
backward in time doesn't matter likewise
when we draw so I erased that's why I
can find excited it remember we drew let
me draw it again you drew this picture
so here's an electron going in with the
positron and creating two photons gamma
gamma I also didn't care too much about
how to draw that intermediate line
whether it's going forward or backward
in time I just do it vertically and
there you think it might matter because
there's an electron or a positron or
both well that's the thing it can be
either one it doesn't matter because the
electron and positron or the same things
in some sense just one is going backward
in time one's going forward in time but
it's the same kind of field enos and I
should also mention yet and yet another
digression is many of you have heard of
this idea called wheelers one electron
universe John Wheeler who was a PhD
thesis advisor for Richard Feynman as
well as the PhD thesis adviser for Hugh
Everett and also for Kip Thorne and a
bunch of other famous physicists so the
story goes that one day Fineman gets a
phone call from wheeler and wheeler says
I think I know why
every electron in the universe has the
same mass in charge and Fineman says
it's 3:00 in the morning what are you
doing and Wheeler says it's because
they're all the same
electron this is closely related to this
idea that in a diagram like this there's
only one line for the electron that is
both representing the electron and the
positron right
the idea of Wheeler was that the
electron goes forward in time then
occasionally goes backward in time and
that goes forward in time and if you
drew the Fineman diagram for the whole
universe there would only be one
electron going back and forth and some
complicated zigzag so many of you have
heard that some of you have heard that
theory probably few of you have heard it
is wrong and that is not correct that
theory so a lot of people sometimes ask
me like what ever happened to that
theory why don't people talk about that
it's wrong and we know it's wrong it was
a very clever idea not all clever ideas
turn out to be right the reason why
every electron has the same mass and
charge as every other electron is
because they're both they're all very
vibrations perturbations in the same
underlying quantum field okay we already
knew the answer to that question why are
all the electrons the same mass in
charge they're the same quantum field
vibrating in different ways furthermore
we now know that electrons are not
forever electrons can turn into other
particles under the right circumstances
like muons and stuff like that so it's
just not true that there is only one
electron all throughout the universe
there are quantum fields but in the
fiber diagram an electron going one way
in time is the same as a positron going
the other way in time therefore in these
intermediate lines it doesn't matter
okay that's what I wanted to say but
that's not what I wanted to say that was
a digression that got me away from what
I wanted to say let me make this diagram
bigger I can just reuse this diagram
maybe I can make it bigger no I can't
style nope can't make it bigger all
right I need a bigger diagram so I'm
gonna redraw it just one make everything
clear here here's a Fineman diagram
electron positron to photons by the way
yeah nothing yet another thing it's life
going on in Flyman diagrams so I keep
forgetting things that I wanted to say
why not this one why not just consider a
minus e plus two a single photon as a
physical process this is the certainly
exists as a diagram right we it's the
fundamental Lego building block that we
use to make all of our other diagrams
but we don't consider the process of an
electron or positron dilating into just
one Photon why not so I'll give you 10
seconds to see if you can think of the
reason why not we can think of electron
and positron annihilating to two photons
but not one Photon the answer is that
momentum is conserved okay so this
electron and positron they're massive
particles they're moving more slowly
than the speed of light they have a
total net momentum but for the two
particle system and that total net
momentum could be in its rest frame or
it could be whatever but it's certainly
moving slower than the speed of light
right the center of mass of an electron
and positron is always going to move
slower than the speed of light whereas
the photon can move only at the speed of
light so you cannot have a situation
where an electron and a positron
annihilate each other into a single
photon while conserving energy in
momentum they can annihilate into two
photons because two photons they're both
moving the speed of light but in
different directions so the center of
mass of the two photon system can still
be moving at zero speed or whatever
speed the electron and positron removing
and okay that's why we didn't do that
and that way of thinking is very
important for an about to say here
because there is an implication of the
fact that energy and momentum are
conserved so what we can do is we can
sort of complicate our diagrams a little
bit by drawing little arrows for the
momentum call it P 1 and energy e 1 this
also has momentum P 2 e 2 for particle 2
this is particle 3 so it has momentum P
3 and age-3
particle 4 over here has momentum P 4
energy e 4 and so this is y 5 now you're
in let's get complicated because you see
the arrows representing momentum are
separate from the arrows representing
electron Nisour Fermi on number
but okay the point is at every vertex
the total momentum and total energy are
conserved in a fireman diagram as part
of fineman's rules that he made up so
here you have a certain amount of energy
and momentum which I could write in two
different ways which are equivalent to
each other so when p1 comes in it splits
into the momentum coming down let me
just write this as P v e5 and the point
is that p1 equals P 3 plus p5 and
likewise II 1 equals e 3 + e5 and that's
because at this vertex right here p1
splits it goes partly into p3 and e3
partly into p5 and E 5 and then that P
585 recombine so we have p5 plus p2
equals E - nope equals e 4 what am i
doing
clearly missing my brain now p4 that's
what happens at this diagram and
likewise 'if I've + e 2 equals e 4 ok
and then actually is enough to fix what
he 5 has to be if you add these
equations up and check you'll find that
everything is consistent but energy
momentum are related to each other right
for a massive particle or for for any
particle at all there's a relationship
the energy squared equals the momentum
squared plus the mass squared ok
you can't separately decide what the
energy is and what the momentum is this
these quantities P 5 and E 5 will not
obey in general this relation the energy
is just whatever it has to be to satisfy
energy conservation they will obey this
so this these yes this no 4 e 5 is not
true
three-five okay so we have a way of
saying that what we say is that when you
get more colors sorry about that we say
that these ingoing particles this whole
bit here and the outgoing particles this
whole bit here these are real these are
real particles it means exactly what it
means
all the ingoing particles you can make
right you can create some electrons and
some positrons put them in the photons
coming out you can detect right
they're certainly real they're what you
see in your detector but the
intermediate stuff the stuff in between
okay the particle that is neither coming
in nor going out that has a name it is
called a virtual particle in virtual
particles here's the sort of big reveal
virtual particles aren't really
particles virtual particles are a way of
talking about the vibrations in quantum
fields what's really happening here is a
vibrating electron field and a vibrating
positron field two different wave
packets are coming together and when
they overlap all these other fields
start vibrating along with them the
photons electrons etc in different
complicated ways and then something goes
their merry way so this is why in
practice quantum field theory is really
hard to get right and to get rigorous
because we understand what the particles
are doing when they're far away and not
interacting with each other both before
we start and after but when they're on
top of each other the math becomes very
very difficult the Fineman diagram
language says that we can think about
what happens in between as if it were a
set of virtual particles but these
virtual particles do not move at the
right speeds they do not have the right
energies a virtual photon is not
massless the energy of a virtual
particle is not its momentum squared
plus its mass squared in fact the energy
can be anything depending on just making
energy conservation come out right so
they're not really particles but they're
a convenient calculational device that's
why I say apply my diagram is a story
there is a true story which is what is
the amplitude for sir
reaction to happen but the intermediate
steps are calculational device you kind
of know that has to be true because the
real process that you're looking at is
the sum of all of these different
diagrams and all the different diagrams
have different sets of virtual particles
in them they're not exactly the same so
Fineman actually so anyway but that's
that is the way of thinking about
climate diagrams they're they're
calculational devices for doing
calculations in quantum field theory I
just don't want you to take all of the
steps along the way overly literally
okay including the virtual particles in
between now I'll read the reveal Fineman
when he was inventing this he had an
aspiration he was hoping that he was not
coming up with a set of calculational
tools to do quantum field theory better
he was hoping that he was replacing
quantum field theory with a good old
fashioned particle theory the theory of
particles that be created or destroyed
following the rules of these Fineman
diagrams turned out not to be right
again many missteps along the way to any
great idea and it turns out this is a
way of thinking about quantum field
theory not a replacement for it part of
his motivation was the cosmological
constant problem remember we talked last
time about the fact that when you have
fields pervading the whole universe
these fields have energies and the
energies can be added up and if you just
do it naively the quantum mechanical
contribution to the energy of empty
space is infinitely big and this is one
of those things that physicists have
known for a long time but before around
the 1980s they didn't worry about it
that much but some people did so Flyman
worried a little bit about it Philip
Andersson worried about it a little bit
for different reasons but they thought
that this was a problem with quantum
field theory right that it gave an
infinite energy density to empty space
if you could replace the fields with
particles you could get rid of that
infinite energy it didn't work so we are
left with both this wonderfully accurate
calculational device of quantum diamond
diagrams and this somewhat unnatural
formalism of quantum field theory we
don't know what to do about that we
didn't I'm not gonna reveal what to do
about that we still don't know what to
do about the energy density of empty
space but we're thinking and it might be
that we do in one way or the
have to replace quantum field theory but
in the meantime it is absolutely the
best way we have of understanding nature
currently available